And finally,
we reach the intersection of two very
important topics, maps and hashing.
Hash maps are one of the main places
you'll see hash function show up.
In the previous example we were
just using a hash function
to find a place to store keys.
However, maps have keys and values.
You can use the keys as inputs to a hash
function, then store the key value pair
in the bucket of the hash value
produced by the function.
Again since you know the keys in a map
are unique since they belong to a set
you could use a hash function to give
them each their own unique buckets.
You can also design a hash
function to allow for collisions.
In an interview, you'll often be asked
to create a hash table to show that you
understand hashing.
Also that you know the upsides and
downsides of designing a hash function.
However hash maps are very useful
to integrate into algorithms.
Constant time lookups can
really speed up your code.
Keep it in mind and
always think if it'll work first when
thinking through data structures.